this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
light so welcome back to the next
tutorial on cosmology of the V Heros
International winter school on gravity
and
light and again we have some
statements today these are 10 and it's
as I said about cosmology and an
important notion for cosmology
is what a maximally symmetric space is
and by maximally symmetric we mean that
we have the maximal amount of killing
Vector Fields the first statement on
that is homogeneous and isotropic three
manifolds are maximally symmetric
manifolds that is right since
homogeneous produces three killing
Vector fields and isotropy produces also
two so translations and
rotations these are six in total and if
you look at the formula that is D * D +
1 /
2 basically that's the number of
independent components in the
metric and if you plug in the three here
that's 3 * 4 / 2 is 6 in our case is and
these are precisely these six killing
Vector
Fields so that's right therefore these
are maximally symmetric a
five-dimensional manifold can have
maximally 10 linearly independent
killing Vector Fields by the same
formula this is incorrect because 5 * 6
is 30 / 2 is 15 not
10 reman curvature on a maxim symmetric
manifold contains exactly one derivative
the metric no it doesn't we saw that it
contains no derivative of the
metric a maximal isometric 3 manifold
cannot be
flat yes it can for example
consider the spatial part of
FW if we pick Kaa equals zero then we
have this maximally symmetric three
manifold that is flat so this is false
as as well and the last one for part A
would be a maximal symmetric space has
constant sectional
curvature these are the Capas so minus
one 0 and one that we introduced in the
lecture so that's
true B which statements are correct
perfect fluid matter has constant
pressure and constant density over the
whole space time
definitely not because the p which is
the pressure is some function of T and
the row as well so that's
incorrect homogeneous and isotropic dust
and radiation can be modeled as a
perfect fluid that's right so we saw
that um the equation of
state that is this one um for Omega = 1
/ 3 we model radiation and for Omega
equals uh zero we have
dust so that can be modeled and this
equation of state is the equation of a
perfect fluid that's how how we call
that the fredine equations are the
Einstein equations for a spherical
symmetric
vacuum so up to here this would be
correct but it is not a vacuum it is not
necessarily spherically symmetric in
particular it can just be spherically
symmetric in the spatial part so this is
definitely not correct but the main
argument is here vacuum because we put
matter on the right
side the F frw metric with Kappa equals
1 is the metric of a hyperbolic three
manifold if you put a minus here this
would be correct but since there's no
minus this is incorrect remember
remember this Factor 1 / 1 - Kaa R 2 and
Kaa = 1 produces a spherical three
manold the last one all met densities
row of T are proportional to T to the
minus 2 that's right and we calculated
that in the
lectures exercise two killings equation
first before we start deriving killings
equation we want to again think about
what it means for Vector field K to be a
killing Vector
field um and we should give some
interpretation of this condition in
terms of the flow HK associated with
that killing Vector field so the
condition for the vector field K to be a
killing Vector field was that the
derivative on the metric with respect to
this Vector field
vanishes okay so we should give the
interpretation in terms of the flow
where does the flow come into the game
well l k g was defined as h k some
parameter y Lambda the pull back of the
metric minus
G over Lambda and as always I forgot we
need to take Lambda to zero so some
limit Lambda goes to zero over that so
this is some more general form of a
differential
quotient that defines the lead
derivative okay but in order to do the
interpretation here we first need to say
what this flow
HK is really about
so in order to understand that we look
what it does so we look at this
map which takes some value R the Lambda
down here and some point and Maps this
in the manifold again so it gets the
Tuple Lambda p and this is mapped to h k
of this tupal so just pluged in and
normally because this looks a little bit
silly we write H up K down Lambda so
this parameter Lambda jumps here of p
and this one is just gamma P of
Lambda but now you have to ask what is
Lambda what is gamma and I need to tell
you
that and that is the tangent Vector to
the curve gamma at the point p
has to
be the killing Vector
field at the point P that is the vector
at this
point if we have this
condition then we call
HK the flow of the vector field
K okay so we maybe draw some
picture and and to use again the
terminology introduced these
gamma here are the integral curves
through the vector field and if we do
that for all of the points then we call
the parameter um subgroup of um integral
curves this we call the flow so this
here would be the h
k Lambda and the Lambda varies in this
direction and the point P do we plug in
here sets somehow the starting point and
if you plug in Q and Q is down here then
we arrive at this integral curve so this
would then be gamma Q of Lambda this up
here would be gamma P of Lambda that's
the idea of the flow and as we know we
can use such maps to pull back tensorial
objects for example the metric so we
look at the metric here for example and
look at the metric here but in order to
compare them we pull them back here and
we look at the difference of these two
and the meaning of the Le the The
Killing condition here is that they
don't differ so the metric here and here
is the same and that's how it is
mathematically
encoded
okay next question show that a vector
field K is killing if and only if NAA a
k down B plus NAA b k down a equals
zero and this one is called
killings
equation okay so you may have seen this
before but now we want to do the
derivation of this
result okay so the only thing that we
know is that that K is a killing Vector
field so the only thing that we can
write down is l k on G we look at this
in
coordinates equals
zero and now we try to write some equal
signs in order to arrive at some
expression that looks like
that okay so the lead derivative on a 02
tensor consists of three components so k
c d by
dxc acting on
gab now we have the indices down
therefore
A+
and now we introduce the summation index
down here and the derivative d by
DX um a acts on K C so the sum is here
now we do the same for the other index
so this is
G um oh sorry here's some thing going
wrong this should be a
b just replace the a by the C and shift
the a over here that's the rule and now
we leave the A and put the C here and
then we get Dy DX B because the B from
here moves there and this acts on not on
X but on K
and the index that needs to be summed
over is C so
that's basically it so the lead
derivative in
components okay so the next thing to do
is we somehow need to produce gamma
symbols why because here is the
covariant derivative and um if we write
this in coordinates completely we get
some
gamas and therefore we probably need to
recall the definition of the gamas and I
put this up here so some gamma AB b
c was defined as 12 g a
d and in here we have the metric g b d
comma c i again used the short notation
here uh g a a d comma
B plus oh that's not right the a can't
be down
here so what is it we have b c and now
we have C D comma V that's good and here
is no plus but a minus G and now we have
b c comma d That's the definition of the
gamas sorry for
the small space here but you should know
that by
heart okay so we see that here for
example this would be g a comma C that
looks similar to this
one and we should try to produce these
two terms here so what we could do have
a closer look at this one and pull the
metric in
here this produces
some mistake that we make and this needs
to be
compensated so this looks like g a b
comma C plus and now I make the mistake
by writing d by dxa on
GCB KC so here I would have to evaluate
this by the product rule but here only
one of the two
summons appears that means we need to
subtract the other one and the other one
is just the K C untouched and here we
have G CB comma a so this here is the
same as this expression just
inverse application of the product
rule here we do the same that means we
have d by
dxb on g a c k
c and to compensate this mistake that we
make we write K C and here it is g a c
comma
B
okay and now we do a little
reordering and write this a little bit
shorter so G CB k c is nothing but K
down
B so this would be k b comma a because
we derive by a same holds for this term
that means we have a plus K and now it
is down a comma B and this looks quite
good but we need to make the partial
derivative here into a variant
derivative but fortunately we have the
gamas that we first need to find but I
assure you that they are there so we
write this as the KC that appears here
and here and here pulls out so we can
put this in front and what's left is g a
b comma C minus G CB comma a minus g a c
comma B
okay and now
we need to have a closer look at this
one
so
mhm we just keep these two and do this
step by step plus so K up C can also be
written as K down let's say d we have no
D in in there but G
DC okay so these together just would
pull the index up and in here we
have what I want to do is put the minus
here so this one goes out and therefore
we have G CB comma a plus g a c comma B
these two but with the opposite sign and
here it
is um this is g a b comma C
okay that's
it and now we know that the metric is
symmetric in these
indices and what that means is we just
have twice the gamma here so this is KD
and now we have
twice the
gamma because if you remember here was
some Factor 1 12 and here we put the
two and that is now let me see the C is
summed over so what we have here is a d
up and Su a b
down so we sum over the D and ab remains
and the index
structure
fits and now we can do
some reordering so we know that this is
symmetric in these indices so we can
distribute the two gamas onto these two
here we missed some comma I'm
sorry uh and that means we have
k a comma B minus and now it is gamma d
a k
d
plus k b comma a this one minus the
other GMA that's KD ba
KD okay but this can be short written as
NAA a acting on K the be
component plus this plus here
NAA uh what is it b k the eighth
component okay and if you compare
up here that's the
same so we arrived at the right result
and since we just started from l k on G
which is zero we derived the killings
equation okay that's it for this
exercise we continue with exercise
three in exercise three we want to
estimate the age of the universe by some
specific met
model
and we start by first
deriving the conservation equation that
we need in order to manipulate the
fredman equations such that we can get
the desired
result so the exercise is the energy
momentum tensor for a perfect fluid is
given by this expression that you might
know from the lectures or somewhere else
and this UA is some
Tim
like vector or the components of some
time like
vector
okay we want to choose these
coordinates
and the condition that we use
is basically the energy conservation or
the energy momentum conservation that um
followed from the differential identity
that we showed last time that is or the
twice contracted differential Bank
identity that is that we have nabla a on
G A be
component this is
zero and if this holds and the Einstein
equations hold then this holds without
the u u here but adding the U will
change
nothing but this will just make it a
little easier for us to derive
this okay so we start by evaluating this
condition so nabla a on T A be component
times
U but this is just NAA a t
a0o maybe some minus in here but this
doesn't interest us because because the
other side is zero and this would cancel
so that's the expression where we start
and we just write this so NAA a t
a0 is okay so we have t a0 comma
a now indices are up therefore plus now
we have gamma here's some T and for the
other index as well gamma and the T now
we need to distribute the indices so we
derive by a therefore the a goes in both
cases
here here goes some dummy summation
index and here we put the a up here and
then the N goes there and then we are
missing something that is the zero here
that stays untouched and here it's the
other way around the zero goes here
and the a stays and the N goes there
that should be
right
okay
so in order to calculate this we need
the
gamas and I will give them to you so
this is gamma A N A is equal to gamma
alpha n Alpha where the A's run over 0 1
two and three and the alphas just one
two
three this holds as we showed in the
lecture and this gamma symbol is given
by a DOT over a and here's some
Delta alpha alpha but we know what that
is we contract here and this yields the
dimension in this case for the spatial
um indices A3 so we know what this guy
is is that
right ah okay I was too fast here I
wanted to put some zero here so this is
now correct and we'll see in a minute
why we need
that maybe you do this now okay so we
know that
the zero component if we have um the row
zero the column zero
then this has to be a zero too because
otherwise there are no contributing
entries in the energy momentum tensor
therefore this is row Dot and by dot we
denote the derivative so this one has to
become a zero and of course this one as
well so we derive the first component
that is just row because to P here
cancels and then derived by T we denote
this as
row dot now comes
A+ and now we argue here the same way
this has to be a zero therefore this has
to be a zero and now we can use the
gamma that I wrote down here maybe a
little bit fast but nevertheless that's
true so what we have here is 3 * a DOT
over a we use this and t0 0 is again
just
row okay now it gets a little more
complicated but nevertheless we will do
that and we write this as gamma
Z and now we put Greek indices
here Alpha Beta over which we sum this
is symmetric therefore the um order
doesn't matter better and we know that
in the gamma there's some zero anywhere
then only the spatial part contributes
that means we can rewrite this as just a
summation over the Greek indices which
are the spatial ones and now we can have
a look at this
guy and this was given in the lecture as
well and this is a * a DOT time gamma
Alpha
Beta where gamma Alpha Beta down was
G Alpha
Beta uh what do I want to say so G Alpha
Beta was a s * gamma Alpha Beta so this
was just the spatial part and in the
whole metric we want to multiply that by
the factor a
s
good so we know what
uh this one here is so this is + a * a
DOT and we have some gamma Alpha Beta
here and now we have to look at the
spatial part of the energy momentum
tensor that is just P * gab but G
upab and just the spatial part so Alpha
Beta is 1/ a s gamma Alpha
Beta okay so here goes some 1 / a sar
gamma Alpha
Beta and here's the
sum and again this whole contraction
here produces the dimension that is
again some three so we have row Dot and
now we evaluate this two cancels against
this one so we have a do over a the same
as here this one pulls out these two
yield the dimension therefore this is 3
a DOT over a row plus P I forgot the
P this P where is it this P I
forgot so that's it and this should be
zero and if you have a look this is the
desired
result okay
so to summarize we exploited the
condition that the coent derivative of
the energy momentum tensor in one of
these directions yields zero which
follows from the twice contracted
differential by Yanke identity that we
derived last time and then you have to
play around with the indices here and
look at the nonvanishing components here
and then if you do this care hope y you
arrive at the right result as I hope yes
so that's good and I suppress the of T
over here because that is not that
important
here okay so in the next
question for p equals Omega * row that
means we have a perfect fluid uh we
should solve this
equation uh we should solve this
equation above for row and then use the
fredman equations um with Vanishing
spatial curvature that means here is no
contributing term to derive an anous
differential equation for the a so we
want basically to eliminate this row and
replace by something with with a or a
DOT or
whatever okay so the first step as it is
given in the question we should have a
closer look at this expression and we
better write this in the given form so
this is -3 a DOT over a row +
P
um yes that's right and this is of
course the same as row dot equal
-3 a DOT over a and now we know the
equation of State here that means we can
pull out the row and here it is 1 plus
Omega good now we divide by row that
means row dot over Row = 3 * a do/ A+
Omega and this is the same as d by
DT the natural logarithm of row and here
the same thing d by
DT logarithm of
a * 1 +
Omega now we continue up here so we
integrate this once so we get log row =
-3 log
Ln a * 1 +
Omega now we take
this some X of that so we get row
equals uh we know what happens with
factors in front of the logarithm they
just go up here that means what we have
is a to the what is that - 3 * 1 + Omega
and we suppress the constant or we could
introduce it as well so here plus C and
then this is some C TI in front of
here that's right so that's the
expression for the row and we should
plug this in to that equation so star
into
1 so we get a DOT over a s = 8 piun G /
3 * this constant * a to
the- 3 * 1 + Omega and that's our result
because we wanted some
aous autonomous sorry uh differential
equation for the A's so here we just
have A's in there the rest are constants
so that's the
result now in the next question the
differential equation should be
solved and I write it down again so this
was a DOT over a squared and that was
equal to 8 Pi g/ 3 times our constant C
Tilda that we may suppress as well but
doesn't matter and here we have a to - 3
* 1 + Omega that was the differential
equation and the unz here is given so we
just plug this in here and what I will
do is just collect all the constants
that appear here and pull them into some
new constant
D um and what we have here is a DOT that
means derivative with respect to the
time so here we have
t Alpha minus 1 the alpha here again
went into the D down here we have t to
the alpha that is squared and here all
these factors went in there as well so
what we have is a nope not a but
t t to the- 3 * Alpha * 1 +
Omega okay now we do some
reordering that means we have D
equals here the alpha somehow cancels
and we get T Theus 2 and put this to the
other side and that
means we get some plus two
here okay and since here some invisible
t to the 0o in order for this equation
to hold we need to say that - 3 Alpha *
1 + Omega + 2 = 0 otherwise this equal
sign cannot
hold and from that we can read off the
alpha we bring this to the other side
divide by 3 and by this so this is 2
over 3 * 1 +
Omega
okay and what I forgot to mention is
that we just consider omegas not equal
to minus one because then this would
vanish and then this would not be a
solution of that one so we found the
alpha and therefore can write down the a
of T which is then the constant c
times um T to
2/ 3 *
1 +
Omega
and by the way we want this C to be
greater than zero we will need this
later um and this makes sense because
the St scale factor should not decrease
in our model
here okay we continue with the next
question where we actually arrive at the
age of the
Universe um and the question is the
following so we should use this result
of the previous question to write down
an equation for H of T which is the
Hubble
function defined by a do over a and then
estimate the age of the universe uh only
filled with dust for today's value of
the Hub constant given by by that uh and
afterwards we should do the same thing
not for dust but for
radiation so we do this first in general
uh look at this function so h of T was
defined by a DOT over
a and if you look at our
a this is just
some well I write it down so this is the
C cancels of course and we get t to the
2 3 * 1 + Omega minus one because we
derive one time and then we have this
thing
times well this one comes
down 2 * 1 + Omega divided by just t to
the 2 over 3 * 1 +
Omega okay now we cancel everything that
can be cancelled here is one plus so
this one goes against this one so what's
left is 2
over 3 * 1 + Omega
* 1 / T that's all that's
left okay and now we look at
first the dust model that means Omega
equals z equ equalent to zero
pressure so that means we have h0
equals now we plug that in
here so that yields 2 over 3
t0 now we can solve that one for
t0 uh which is 2 over 3
h0 and now plug in the given Hubble
constant for today or last week or
something like that so we used that and
the result would be 2/3 *
13 * 10 the 9
years well that estimates the age of the
universe as some value if we assume that
everything is just filled with dust
the same goes for
radiation so we have omega equals 1
over3 and then we can just write out
what this is so Omega equal 1 over 3
that means we get some one2 here and we
have this one and now this gets
6.5 10 9
years so you you see for
different models that we impose we get
different results for the age of the
universe for for some estimate of that
of course this whole thing is much more
complicated but I think it's quite nice
to have such an easy model and get such
good
results okay so that's it so far and the
last question is not about the age of
the universe but whether the expansion
is accelerating or not and this will
again depend on the
Omega and in order to talk about the
expans of the um the rate of the
expansion we need to look at a double
dot which is
then 2 over 3 * 1 + Omega that was the
factor from the first derivative and now
we get another factor which
is this one minus
one and in the exponent we have t to the
what is that 2 over 3 * 1 + Omega - 2
now so that can easily be derived I
missed the factor C and here you see why
I wanted this to be greater than zero
because otherwise I would have trouble
to uh say what whether this complete
Factor here in front is greater or
smaller than zero cuz that's the um
statement on acceleration or
deceleration okay in so we want to maybe
made in total so this is greater than
zero this is of course also greater than
zero because T is greater than zero
and therefore we look at roots of this
Factor and this can only be zero if 2
over 3 * 1 + Omega =
1 it should be
right let's continue and then we will
check if this is right but I think so so
that means we have multiply that over
here
so 1 + Omega is equal to 23
this over here the three stays that's
good and this means Omega = -
1/3 so this is the point where we have
zero
acceleration of the expansion and now we
can say that if Omega is larger than 1
over3 and if Omega is larger than minus
1 over3 sorry um we can make statements
about the a dot
dot so that means larger than minus 1/3
we could for instance plug in zero if we
plug in zero here what do we get we get
2 over 3 * 2 over 3 -
1 that means this one gets negative this
is positive therefore here the
acceleration
is not acceleration so the expansion is
decelerating and here we have it the
other way
around so you see for different meta
models we get different statements on
the expansion of the universe namely
whether it's accelerating or
decelerating and as you see we have
measured that the expansion is
accelerating that's one of the results
of present measure Ms and that means the
Omega in this simple model um must be
negative but we cannot associate normal
mattera to that so this would maybe be
some indic indicator for dark matter or
dark
energy but of course only in this very
very simple model that we
choose okay so this completes
this tutorial see you next time thanks